[MUSIC PLAYING]
You're out there fighting
with Angelina Jolie.
It's like, what
else do you need?
Why not?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The Eternals are a
group of Super Heroes
who have been around for
at least 7,000 years.
Created by the Celestials,
sent to Earth to protect
humankind from the Deviants.
Fighting to prevent
the end of the world,
or the end of human
civilization as we know it,
so I don't think the stakes
get much higher than that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
For me, to be an Eternal
has many different meanings.
As the character, It
gives me a sense of duty,
because I am in
charge of the mission.
And personally, it gives me
a sense of hope for change.
I am Latina, and also
Arab, and also in my 50s.
It would have been almost
unimaginable that I
would become a superhero now.
I feel like what
it means to be
an Eternal is
becoming a reflection
of people who have been here.
And I think that
the Eternals let
people have an insight into how
wonderful humankind has been.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If I could, I
would only work with
Chloé Zhao from here on out.
If Chloé called me
and was like hey,
I'm just going to put
you in everything I do,
I would be like, great.
It's an incredible
group that came
together to make this film.
We all come from very different
backgrounds and cultures,
and it's an amazing
mix of people.
Once we finally came
together, and we're
all in our super suits
and got to see each other,
it was the most
amazing experience.
I think I cried.
I think I cried, and it still
is one of the most memorable
moments I've ever had.
It's like a big family.
Everyone was lovely.
A big movie of that scale is a
bit intimidating to go on to.
Chloé was our captain.
She listened and took my
ideas on building the action.
Great teamwork.
Great communication.
I was very happy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
She shows her primary super
strength to be a speedster,
but also very intelligent.
I think that combination
of both of those
makes Makkari very powerful.
How am I alike or
different from Ikaris?
Well, very different.
I can't fly, I can't shoot
lasers out of my eyes,
I don't have super
strength, all of the things
I would very much like to have.
My character,
although she's an alien
and doesn't have any children,
has a very strong sense
of motherhood for the
rest of the Eternals,
and I have always had that.
She likes to boss
people around, and I
have always had that, too.
She's a free spirit.
She's very loyal.
I would say I have quite a lot
of overlap with her, actually.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of my favorite
moments to shoot, I suppose,
was filming in Camden in London,
where I was on a crane on wires
and I'm flying and
landing on the street.
It was really fun, just because
I'm above the bridge in Camden,
and you get to see this kind
of bird's eye view of streets
that I've walked for many years.
So I got to see it
from a different angle.
I am excited to see the
spectacle and the big action
pieces, and also
the more intimate
character driven beats as well.
This is an
incredibly epic movie.
I mean, the scale of
it, the story of it,
it's unlike anything I think
Marvel has ever done before.
As far as ensembles go,
this is one of the best
ensembles I've ever been with.
You know, it was an incredibly
emotional ride, which I think
the viewer will experience
when they watch it,
because it's thousands
of years in the making.